[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai passé deux ans dans un bon
architecte le camp des sénateurs
ces deux seules années où j'ai travaillé
depuis je suis jamais retourné j'avais
21 ans
j'ai au moins le temps de vivre ma vie
plutôt que de me la faire voler
je me sens pas comme une exception
on est quatre milliards et demi pauvres
sur la planète dont fait partie de la
majorité des gens qui vivent surtout
c'est les autres qui sont une minorité
moi je cherchais
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis quand même tout en comptant le
trouver des pierres aussi parce que je
suis content de les faire revivre quoi
ces voix là ça me fait toujours une
certaine émotion le savoir voilà des
gens qui verra une famille et tout ça
c'est abandonner cassé c'est toujours
triste parce que les gens ils ont quitté
ont l'habitude d'enlever hlm peut-être
quoi alors que bon il y avait quand même
moyen au moins d'y vivre
je pense quand même que ils ont perdu en
qualité de vie même s'ils ont gagné en
confort
j'évite 34 ans pierre quoi peut-être
plus ça j'ai pas tout cherché partout
l'année prochaine on sera obligé de
prendre le bus à 6 heures du matin non
7h05 on va retourner à l'école ça manque
peut pas voir les copines
ouais mais quand même envie de se lever
à 6h tech en train badigeonner le ciel
en bout mais je vais faire
j'ai fini mais ça sera trop marrant il
ya de quoi douter quand tu pars à bout
sur une toile et bat sapin dans la
réalité ça trop sympa imagine tu veux
qu'ils aient de la pub à un endroit sa
troupe et du soleil à un autre et de la
neige à un autre il faudra avoir en
permanence le truc météo enfin je veux
dire sur les pays pour savoir si en
afrique ils ont besoin d'eau qu'ils ont
besoin d'eau tu mets de la plus sur ton
tableau
j'ai cherché volontairement une maison
isolée où il n'y avait pas de route où
il n'y avait pas d'eau pas d'électricité
générée c'était des choses quand même
que je voulais je voulais me couper pour
me retrouver et moi même parce que on
est on est embarqué depuis tout le temps
dans un effet de groupe et on n'est pas
nous-mêmes finalement on est on est un
peu ce qu'elle groupe quoi j'ai médité
pas loin de dix ans sur moncayo au
milieu des brebis
voilà pour trouver de fil d'ariane de la
vie courage de résister
j'avais des bribes de réponses
je n'arrivais pas à les assembler pauvre
poulain on plante on récolte manche
commence à nous saisir
ça nous est quand même radio sans pub
quand on tente une petite graine béton
qu'on voit ce que tu as pousse à un
tibia l'école n'a pas planté autant de
graines de haricot qu'on récolte y a pas
besoin d'avoir une centaine d'hectares
comme ont chacun peter blake savard et
elle a nourri même pas leur famille une
personne ça nourrit surtout trade
agricole et basse
on est souriant hiver ces allocations le
4 le 5 ans requise on laisserait au
système bancaire
c'est vrai qu'on est compatible surtout
pas
parce que cet argent là il le prête de
près topo pour le faire fructifier les
gens mettent en moins tout ce système ne
veut pas se contenter
et d'ailleurs c'est aussi pour ça que je
reste volontairement pour ça finalement
c'est la révolution pacifique
là c'est la révolution reccord investir
à la maison reste à la maison si t'es
rien et tout s'écroule
bonjour ordinale c'est la force de
l'inertie
[Musique]
non
il
regardez ah qu'est-ce qu'on s'écaille
en fait elle m'attend pas
[Musique]
nouvelle fait quinze jours avec des
températures entre eux - raid - 30 noms
des changements la maison la propriété
est décédé la fille en a hérité
ils ont pas vraiment entendu ils n'ont
pas vraiment voulu rester dans le même
rapport en tous les cas même si j'y suis
toujours occupants à titre gratuit est
un jeu et ses biens a eu donc il faut
s'en aller ou pas il faut partir j'ai
donc décidé de me construire de maisons
j'ai commencé j'ai posé le permis a1
le permis de construire mais après je
suis quand même resté trois ans sans
revenir sur le chantier parce qu'il ya
eu des petits changements dans ma vie
privée pas déjà année les enfants soient
arrivés j'ai plutôt privilégier notre
relation familiale
donc voilà je suis resté quand même
trois ans moi je suis pas le papa des
deux petites des deux petites est bon
c'est pas facile non plus de se faire
adopter
voilà je trouvais important ce
passage-là de se faire adopter
après bon maintenant tout va bien on
peut reprendre de chantier c'est une
zone non constructible j'étais un peu
obligé zigzaguer avec les systèmes même
beaucoup et comme c'était une zone
agricole
j'ai un peu prévu un bâtiment agricole
transforma 20 habitations
donc c'était six boxes à chevaux 1 2 3
de ses côtés trois de l'autre la grande
porte d'entrée c'était le couloir
d'alimentation et puis ma petite partie
là-bas garage-atelier ben c'était la
grange quoi je me suis dit que les
riches il faut que ça y est que la
législation il s'autorise tout moi je me
suis dit tiens les pauses si on faisait
pareil ce serait pas mal donc c'est ce
que j'ai fait mais ça marche ça marche
aussi ça c'est vrai on a même si ça
paraît assez fou ça marche
jo les photos vont du vin diouf tient il
ya une pierre de plus au sud à vence où
vous y trouvez mais c'est bien ça fait
rigoler les gens j'ai pas forcément j'ai
les retours trop vite je suis sur mon
temps tu revois la vision des choses
[Musique]
par contre connu que ses feux dans la
grande tradition d'un des pires ennuis
le site du secteur qui jamais entendu
quelqu'un dire cela c'est mal fait jaser
façon vous regarde pas mais on se pose
des questions comment s'est organisée
que le propriétaire mais ça se pendait
au nez avec mon propriétaire habite
actuellement non comme celui là mais
j'ai pas tué je suis propriétaire
je crois que stand up nous prenons ça ça
ne regarde pas plus non ça c était ça
fait partie des zigzags pour arriver à
contre courant contre d'accord après la
perrière marc vendu la parcelle un
accord je crois que tu as oui peut être
une fois que le permis ça qu'il a eue
tendu abbas a souhaité passer le permis
au nom du grec et après un prêt
le jacquemart vendu la parcelle où j'ai
fait un transfert de permis de montrer
tout surcoût des choses
donc c'est comme quoi c'est possible
donc aujourd'hui j'ai fait je suis
propriété copropriétaire avec ma
compagne ou de cette parcelle qui m'a
vendu pour rien du tout j'ai acheté de
1300 m² pour santoro cui au prix du goût
de terrain agricole 3 60 euros
ça fait pas bon ok bon les finis c'est
bien et a un air tantôt
elles sont faites au à la farine de
petit épeautre au lait de soja est la
grèce de coco que des produits locaux
s'est plaint carbone car on est déjà
tout un sérieux toute l'année alors on
se fait plaisir
non
si tu pouvais te servir s'étonner non il
est trop lourd
ouais voilà
normalement le fait d'avoir de l'avoir
fait à temps le monde j'ai soudainement
une petite pensée pour la tuerie de
pensée pour les pauvres qui n'ont rien à
manger moi je retravaille d'avoir une
pensée pour les riches contre eux mangé
depuis que malade mais bien parce que ça
j'ai trop manger je suppose que c'est
absurde c'est quoi prête avait une
pathologie qu'il faut dénoncer cet amour
cette passion de l'argent pour arriver à
rien tous les riches nous montre
quotidiennement qui sont dans la
satisfaction
mon envie de mons la bûche à y arrive un
moment il va falloir qu'on leur dise
quand même falloir qu'on leur dise j'ai
pas il ya plein de gens qui l'ont dit
avant noël mais je dirais pas le christ
la rade jeudi
il râle il a demandé aux riches de
dilapider leurs biens de son fils il a
dit qu'on ne peut pas servir deux
maîtres dieu et l'argent même si je suis
pas croyant quoi fouad m
il a dit des choses qui sont en vérité
ça ne sert à rien du tout tu vois on
vient de noël mais on en parle tout
séjour de nous avoir c'est posséder être
c'est exister si l'homme était
caractérisée par son avoir parce qu'ils
possèdent dont l'appel rien à voir
humain en tous les cas chez nous on
appelle un être humain quand on parle
d'un homme on distinct est rumeur dit
pas si un avoir humain donc la course
qui caractérise l'être humain ce sont
des choses qu'on ne peut pas acheter
avec de rares l'intelligence
cette unité la tolérance la compassion
toutes des choses qu'il n'y a aucune
boutique donc avec l'argent peut acheter
que du concret c'est des loisirs c'est
des plaisirs artificiels et ses plaisirs
sont des compensations à notre mal être
donc moi je me suis dit tiens si
j'arrivais à résoudre le problème du mal
être si j'essayais intérieurement avec
dans le dialecte ça m'éviterait d'aller
gagner de l'argent pour faire de la
compensation mon mal être
donc j'ai trouv j'ai surtout cherché
dans ce sens là
puis je me suis aperçu que ça marchait
très bien on est comme qui dirait pressé
en fait ont précédé et b alors
anormalement l'attribution des cadeaux
qui sont donc ces pour pau pour lui
c'est bienvenu merci la plus ses marques
et un cadeau tu déplacer qu'à 12
si je fais pas la mécanique
on n'a pas de voiture on a pour les
moyens tous les corps
bon après c'est pour une obligation non
plus et d'avoir une voiture mais c'est
toujours mort pour le moment ça nous
permet de bouger un peu courte mais
après tu sais ce qui prend avec une
voiture neuve il part avec les mêmes
soucis que moine renom ils ont d
assurance de rapatriement tous ah bon
nous on n'a rien eux te permets moi je
suis toujours rendre revenu avec mu
voiture à jamais rester en rade d'obama
au temps des séries
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y en a 7 2 pouces
oui mais après il ya deux ans
[Rires]
rapidement ça qui est plus petit que le
tient quand même mais que chez ces bleus
dès que tu as toutes les affaires
qu'est-ce qu'on a me surprend les
adresses les fusibles de tu les prends
en passant poule
que faire mais si j'ai fait mais au
pardon j'ai pris j'ai pris le dossier
l'inspecteur académique
la led pour la gendarmerie non ça ce gpo
navette pour la gendarmerie
mais non voyons sur l'être qui te cacher
là bas tagliani d'intego jamais dans ton
sac c'est nous mais ces chaussures là
c'est à qui ça et là et là tu dises
emmène tuvalu mai dernier sexy moi oui
ça va mais les plus vers la sortie
ça c'est le mien
[Musique]
chacun
je commence une carotte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est là bas dans le trou là qu'hier une
petite parcelle de terre qui en tente
comme ça où je vous ai tiens ce serait
bien de venir et faire une grotte
creusée une grotte faire un habitat très
bonne et je me disais bon ben voilà
suffit de faire un trou du vitrage
devant un tu te fais trois trous ça fait
trois pièces quoi est fait et vu qu'ici
le problème c'est la chaleur mais je me
dis que d'habiter sous terre c'est pas
plus mal quoi
la vie est quand même plus facile ainsi
il ya quand même à manger et quand même
quatre ans teddy salade de temps peut
les manger dit stature mais une graine à
mesure que tard mange ça fait le tour
quoi
au collège je voyage au bout du monde et
virgules quand je dois refaire mais le
roman les illustrations de livres santos
a miné le précieux agents secrets
virgules je suis tour à tous chasseurs
de gros ou agents secrets qu'à 50 % de
chômeurs de moins de 25 ans en espagne
c'est que un jeune sur deux ne sait pas
quoi de sa vie il n'a pas
d'espoir dans persécution des chrétiens
qui dorment sous les ponts à barcelone
des jeunes aux pics de là ils vont à la
soupe populaire maintenant six millions
de personnes sur la côte nippone
moi quand les jeunes ont manifesté mon
niveau quand il n'y a pas une
manifestation qui aurait dépassé qu'est
ce que vous attendez de l'état qui vous
donne du travail qui vous les gars des
terres qui sont pas cultivés d'amener
cliqué votre nourriture j'ai jamais vu
un indigné par isna on va pas changer la
crise et le système aujourd'hui qui est
en crise en changeant simplement d'un
vote à gauche mais si on attend que
l'état nous dise qu'il faut faire on est
dans les mouvements book loi or ces
mouvements bourgeois ils vont pas
inventé l'alternatif y sont pas pressés
ils ont à manger ils sont logés ils sont
bien ils ont tout ce qu'il faut
moi j'ai jamais belles pousses que ce
soit un mec de gauche de droite hôtels
poussent pareil pour moi je n'ai pas
besoin de ces gens là je les ai je les
reconnais pas j'ai pas envie de mettre
un place déjà
soit on paie des gens de domination des
gens qui sont au dessus puis décide à ma
place de ma vie qui réfléchissent à ma
place que ça veut dire que moi je suis
trop con pour réfléchir à marie que je
suis trop con pour décider comment je
dois rire et ça je veux pas d'accord non
polluant de paris on peut voir ses
crochets qui te renifleurs est en bord
de sous bois aux petits bonds les pneus
mais c'est encore discuté des tricks
je veux dire je fais pas exprès de
rouler avec des pneus usés c'est parce
que tout simplement parce que j'ai pas
vraiment les moyens d'acheter du neuf
mais si jean dame est très bonne à jeter
une bien jolie montre tout de suite n'y
a pas de problème donc c'est aussi une
façon discute quoi c'est bon
nous on appelle voilà on n'a pas
l'électricité dont on a pas de facture
n'a pas on n'a pas de loyer on n'a pas
on a pas de facture d'eau on a
on n'a pas de budget
tiens si l on n'a pas de budget alcool
on n'a pas de budget sorties ont une ou
deux fois on va au cinéma quand tu es
vraiment un film qui nous dit on n'a pas
de budget fringues parce que c'est de la
récupération ou de la fabrication maison
on n'a pas de budget
pour envahir hi-fi matériel tous ces
trucs là on n'a pas non plus ordinateur
non plus donc c'est évident que si les
gens pour vraiment le compte de leurs
dépenses ce mensuel il y en a déjà toute
une partie que nous on a pas et donc ça
veut dire que sur cette dépense qu'on
n'a pas on peut mettre une partie dans
une cagnotte vacances
oui
je veux remporter ma compte
où
en fait on lutte contre le travail
clandestin en utilisant le rsa
jean paul l'a demandé
un an et demi
c'était surtout pas la part la mairesse
à la mairie ce qui nous avait enquiquiné
l'athénée au tribunal pour les enfants
donc non ça les dérange savent pas qu on
vit ça les dérange je pense débrouille à
faire deux trois petites bricoles à
droite à gauche
bon ben voilà comme ça on fait plus rien
et puis ils savent de quoi on risque
font envie avec leur argent
le marché de l'eau par les manceaux
je pense à toi
[Applaudissements]
neko jacques 10 dont il ya plein de
fleurs qui sont en préparation
bon là ça fait deux mois qu'ils aient un
temps infernal n'a juste eu le temps de
préparer un peu le jardin entre deux
averses
une journée y voler par ci par là et un
retard au jardin on va arriver quand
même fin juin après ça veut dire qu'il
reste juillet août de correct arrivé en
septembre
ici à cette altitude on sait déjà qu'il
ya des gelées la nuit qui est donc ça ça
fait juste ça fait quand même juste pour
avoir des haricots pour avoir à des
choses si jamais l'automne ne se
prolonge pas avec le bhoutan et puis que
ben
en tous les cas on aura beaucoup de
pertes au jardin c'est évident on aura
quand même à manger mais voilà
[Musique]
m
à
une situation d'impasse et c'est quoi
ton truc que ce à quoi on sait pas j'ai
eu une telle ier deuxième est monté au
majeur bien la peur la faim c'est donc
aussi aidé parallèle des primes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les interdictions ça marche avec celui
qui est conditionné les autres lots
qu'ils s'en foutent
ici c'est la quatorzième ruines où je
viens chercher des pierres donc sur les
quatorze héroïne
j'ai eu très peu d'ennui bon j'ai pas
demandé j'ai jamais demandé
d'autorisation pour venir chercher les
terres parce que sinon et quelques-unes
j'ai demandé ça a été non la réponse
donc les pierres sont là depuis 50 ans
elle reste là
j'ai pas d'argent donc t'as pas d'argent
tu as pas le choix faut trouver la
solution
c'est ce qu'ils font dans tous les pays
pauvres les pauvres ont la solution ici
avait un ancien ministre iranien qui
disait ça il comparaît l'économie
mondiale ou au titanic
il disait que sur le titanic mais voilà
ils ont ils ont caché la catastrophe
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas assez de
canots de sauvetage pour tout le monde
en disant ben voilà nous on est informé
on prendra les canaux puis tous ceux qui
sont tout le personnel ils ont coulé
avec le bateau sauf que bon ça s'est pas
passé comme ça tout le monde a coulé que
s'il avait prévenu les petites mains qui
étaient sur le bateau où ils auraient
trop et des solutions les petites gens
il aurait peut-être privé porte des
cabines pour faire des radios il aurait
à toi il aurait trouvé il aurait sauvé
tout le monde et c'est ça et ses
ministres iraniens disent elle est
pauvre en la solution parce que nous les
riches en sait plus faire et ce qui est
vrai quand tu es quand tu as les
moyettes à peu pas besoin de réfléchir
tu réfléchis plus donc t'as pas la
solution
le petit est en face et maintenant je
m'en fous hu a fait quoi
monta le roi
et
en
on est
j'étais à l'aide du torontois a mis
toute façon d'argent je pensais que ça
allait plus être comme dans des magasins
se retrouvent un petit magasin à dire la
chanson tous et qu'on chantait quand
vous étiez prêt c'est une année de
l'année de rapport aux jardins la
famille ou par exemple les pommes de sa
garde pas bien par rapport à la surface
du jardin qu'on a honnêtement je trouve
que c'est à dire n'a pas réponse est non
alors bon il ya eu le la météo c'est
fragile quoi bah oui c'est évident que
le système qu'il est fragile et bon il
est fragile parce que pendant gouv fr
après il ya le côté idéal et des
réalités non cadre pas avec ce que
j'imaginais notre vie ça c'est évident
mais moi c'est plus voilà c'était les
ouvre un resto du coeur à saint-claude
moi je dis c'est bien c'est bien que
tout ce qui est droit à s inscrire ça
veut dire que voilà il avait peut-être
estimé qu'elle ait tant de personnes ils
se retrouvent avec le double moi je
trouve que c'est bien faut bien montrer
aux systèmes que ça amène à ça à ce qui
est toute une tranche de plus en plus
grande sur terre de population qui
s'appauvrit ce qu'ils s'appauvrissent
qui s'appauvrissent c'est bien d'être
inscrits après si on va plus on va plus
c'est pas un problème ça va pas non plus
se forcer à manger des trucs qu'on veut
pas parce que parce que sans moody's a
donné ce que vous avez dit attends la
première fois que j'ai ramené des
raviolis ouais super on va en manger
bien bon faut bien manger barça mercredi
mois voire bois que maman parfois tu
fais détruit un petit peu au quesnoy
c'est pas tous les jours qu'on a tous
les jours qu'on voit quelqu'un fait
remarquer un gecko lentilles
[Musique]
où
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en fait on était contente quand même
quand on a été déscolarisés parce que on
ai dit vous verrez c'est beaucoup plus
de temps à la maison on pouvait les
dehors beaucoup plus on était quand même
contente quand les six ans qu'on a été à
l'école à la maison 5 en battant 5 ans
je confonds et bah c'est sûr que là ça
nous a fait quand même un changement par
rapport aux horaires quand on se lève
quand on est allé au collège pouvoir il
ya des ya vraiment le du moment où un
petit peu désespéré surtout pendant
l'hiver parce que ben a vraiment dû se
lever le matin alors qu'il ya un mètre
de neige dehors qu'est ce que tu dois
faire un kilomètre à pied
si tu peux pas sortir la voiture et du
coup bah on en profite pour acquérir lui
en lui jusqu à l'abribus ma première moi
c'est maman qui ramène les juges puis
elle s'amuse d'ailleurs maman remontant
les juger à la fin de la petite pente en
maman ou ouais bon après le désavantage
si les devoirs quoi je les félicitations
trop trimestre mais
moi j'ai une bonne riem générale ont
toutes pièces
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand j'allais à l'école je m'arrêtais
le long de la route sur les cimentiers
je regardais travail maçons j'ai regardé
travailler les charpentiers je flânais
et puis je regardais même le bayard le
cantonnier cerveau humain il est
fantastique
cette capacité c'est pas réservés c'est
un entraînement comme le sportif il
entraîne un muscle celui qui a jamais
besoin de réfléchir pour résoudre des
problèmes il réfléchit pas quoi donc ils
s'atrophie aussi le cerveau arrête les
muscles
c'est aussi parce que moi j'ai toujours
eu bien confiance en moi que ça m'a
autorisé tout ça et séminaires si je me
lance dans un projet je me pose pas la
question est-ce que ça va marcher
[Musique]
et puis de savoir faire sur le maintient
une certaine paix intérieure où
finalement les deux mains dans les
poches partout sur terre on va pouvoir
se débrouiller quoi il ya un morceau
doit se faire un abri se faire un feu
pour pouvoir manger
[Musique]
m
sa 404 1 400 à 4 50 à 4 à 484,5 après 84
contre attaque en tête à tête à tête à
tête à 4 50 à 4 40 à 4 50 à 4 4
4 à 4,50 à 4,60
cette rencontre face à face à face à
face à face à face à tant que ça